where i left off in the last video we
talked about how the hemoglobin in red
blood cells is what sops up all of the
oxygen so that it increases the
diffusion gradient or increases the
incentive we could say for the oxygen to
go across the membrane we know that the
oxygen molecules don't know that that
there's
less oxygen here but if you watch the
video on diffusion you know how that
process happens if there's less
concentration here than there the oxygen
will diffuse across the membrane and
there's less inside the plasma because
the hemoglobin is sucking it all up like
a sponge now one interesting question is
why does a hemoglobin even have to
reside within the red blood cells why
don't they just why aren't hemoglobin
proteins just freely floating in the
blood plasma you know that seems more
efficient you don't have to have things
crossing
through in and out of these red blood
cell membranes you wouldn't have to make
red blood cells what's the use of having
these containers of hemoglobin
it's actually a very interesting idea if
you had all of the hemoglobin sitting in
your blood plasma it would actually hurt
the flow of the blood the blood would
become more viscous or more thick it
would become i don't want to say like
syrup but it would become thicker than
blood is right now and by packaging the
hemoglobin inside these containers
inside the red blood cells what it
allows the blood to do is flow a lot
better imagine if you wanted to put
syrup in water if you just put syrup
if you put syrup straight into water
what's going to happen the water is
going to become a little syrupy a little
bit more viscous and not flow as well so
what's the solution if you wanted to
transport syrup in water well you could
put the syrup inside little containers
or inside little beads and then let the
beads flow in the water and then the
water wouldn't be all gooey and that's
exactly what's happening inside of our
blood instead of having the hemoglobin
sit in the plasma and make it gooey it's
it sits inside these beads that we call
red blood cells that allows the flow to
still be
non-viscous
so i've been all zoomed in here on the
alveolus and and these capillaries these
pulmonary capillaries let's zoom out a
little bit just to unzoom out a lot
just to understand how is the blood
flowing and get a better understanding
of pulmonary arteries and veins relative
to the other arteries and veins that are
in the body
so here i copied this from wikipedia
this diagram of the human circulatory
system and here in the back you can see
the lungs let me
let me do it in a nicer in a nice dark
color so we have our lungs here
drew them right like that
those are lungs you can see the heart is
sitting right in the middle and what we
learned in the last few videos is that
we have our little alveoli in our lungs
remember we get to them from our
bronchioles which are branching off of
the bronchi which branch off of the
trachea which connects to our larynx
which connects to our pharynx which
connects to our mouth and nose but
anyway we have our little alveoli
right there
and then we have the capillaries
the capillary so when we go away from
the heart when we go from the way from
the heart and we're going to d delve a
little bit into heart in this video as
well so when blood travels away from the
heart it's deoxygenated it's this blue
color so this right here
is blood
this right here is blood traveling away
from the heart it's going behind these
two tubes right there so this is the
blood going away from the heart
so these this blue that i've just i've
been highlighting just now this these
are the pulmonary arteries so the
pulmonary arteries and then they keep
splitting into arterioles and all of
that and eventually we're in capillary
super super small tubes they
they run right past the alveoli and then
they become oxygenated
they become oxygenated and now we're
talking we're going back to the heart so
we're talking about pulmonary veins so
we go back to the heart so these
capillaries
and the capillaries we get oxygen now
we're going to go back to the heart hope
you can see what i'm doing and now we're
going back to the heart and we're going
to enter the heart on this side we're
going to enter the heart right over you
actually can't even see where we're
entering the heart we're going to enter
the heart right over here and i'm going
to go into more detail on that now we
have oxygenated blood it's red and then
that gets pumped out to the rest of the
body now this is the interesting thing
this is the interesting thing when we're
talking about pulmonary arteries and
veins remember the pulmonary artery was
blue as we go away from the heart we
have deoxygenated blood it's but it's
still an artery then as we go
towards the heart from the lungs we have
a vein but it's oxygenated let me write
that down i wrote that in the last video
but pulmonary
pulmonary
so the
pulmonary artery
artery
no oxygen or maybe i shouldn't write
that i should write deoxygenated because
there might be some oxygen deoxygenated
and then the pulmonary vein
it has oxygen
it has oxygen so that's this little loop
here that we start and i'm going to i'm
going to keep going over the circulation
pattern because the heart can get a
little confusing especially because of
this kind of three-dimensional nature
but what we have is the heart pumps
pumps deoxygenated blood from the right
ventricle you're saying hey why is it
the right ventricle that looks like the
left side of the drawing but it's this
dude's right hand side right this is
this guy's right hand or this is his
right hand
and this is this dude's left hand he's
looking at us right we don't care about
our right and left we care about this
guy's right and left and he is looking
at us he's got some eyeballs and he's
looking at us so this is his right
ventricle actually let me just start off
with the whole cycle so we have
deoxygenated blood coming from the rest
of the body right this is deoxygenated
blood coming from the rest of the body
right here this is actually the name for
this big pipe it's called the inferior
vena cava inferior because coming up
above below actually you have blood
coming up from the arms and the head up
here they're both meeting
right here
right here they meet here in the right
in the right atrium let me label that
and we're going to i'm going to do a big
diagram of the heart in a second so it's
the right
atrium and why are they deoxygenated
because this is blood returning from you
know our legs if we're running or
returning from our brain which needed uh
that that had to use respiration or
maybe we're working out and it's
returning from our biceps but it's
deoxygenated blood it shows up right
here in the right atrium it's on our
left but this guy's right hand side from
the right atrium it gets pumped into the
right ventricle it gets pumped into or
actually passively flows into the right
ventricle the ventricles do all the
pumping then the ventricle contracts and
pumps this blood right here and you
don't see it but it's going behind this
part right here the right it goes from
here through this pipe
so you don't see it i'm going to do a
detail diagram in a second into the
pulmonary artery we're going away from
the heart this was a vein
right this is a vein going
going to the heart this is a vein
inferior vena cava vena cava vein this
is superior vena cava these are veins
they're deoxygenated then i'm pumping
this deoxygenated blood to away from the
heart to the lungs now this deoxygenated
blood this is in an artery right this is
a pulmonary artery then it gets
oxygenated and now it's a pulmonary vein
and once it's oxygenated
it shows up here in the left let me do a
better color like than that it shows up
right here in the left atrium atrium you
can imagine it you know it's kind of a
room with a skylight or that's open to
the outside and in both of these cases
things are entering from above not
sunlight but blood is entering from
above and in on the on the right atrium
the blood is entering from above and in
the left atrium the bud is entering and
remember the left interest on the right
hand side from our point of view on the
left atrium the blood is entering from
above from the lungs from the pulmonary
veins veins go to the heart then it goes
into and i'll go into more detail into
the
left ventricle and then the left
ventricle pumps that oxygenated blood
to the rest of the body to the rest of
the body via the non-pulmonary artery so
everything you so it pumps out let me
make it a nice dark non-blue color so it
pumps it out through there you don't see
it right here the way it's drawn it's a
little bit of a strange drawing or it's
hard to visualize but i'll show it in
more detail and then it goes to the rest
of the body and let me show you that
detail right now
let me show you that detail right now so
we said we have deoxygenated blood let's
label it right here this is the superior
vena cava this is vein
this is a vein from the upper part of
our body from our arms and heads this is
the inferior vena cava this is veins
from our abdomen and from our legs and
the rest of our body so it first enters
the right atrium remember
it's the right hand we call the right
atrium because this is someone's heart
facing us even though this is on the
left hand side it enters through here
it's deoxygenated blood it comes is
coming from veins the body used the
oxygen then it shows up in the right
ventricle right these are
these are valves in our in our heart and
it passively once the right ventricle
pumps and then releases it has a vacuum
and it pulls more blood from the right
atrium it pumps again and then it pushes
it through here now this blood right
here remember this once still is
deoxygenated blood deoxygenated blood it
goes to the lungs to become oxygenated
so this right here
this right here is the pulmonary i'm
using the word pulmonary because it's
going to or from the lungs or it's
dealing with the lungs and it's going
away from the heart it's the pulmonary
sorry the way is artery pulmonary
artery
and it is no it's deoxygenated
deoxygenated
then it goes to the heart rubs let me
rubs up against
rubs up against some alveoli and then
gets oxygenated and then gets oxygenated
and then it comes right back
now this right here and it comes back
just like that
this right here we're going to the heart
so that's a vein we're dealing where
it's it's in the loop with the lungs so
it's a pulmonary
pulmonary vein
and it rubbed up against the alveoli and
got the oxygen diffused into it so it is
oxygenated
oxygenated and then it flows into your
left atrium now the left atrium once
again from our point of view on the
right hand side but from the dude
looking at us it's his left hand side so
it goes into the left atrium now in the
left ventricle after it's done pumping
it expands and so that that blood that
oxygenated blood flows into the left
ventricle then the left ventricle the
ventricles are what do all the pumping
it squeezes and then it pumps the blood
it pumps the blood into the aorta now
the aorta this is an this is an artery
this is
an artery why is it an artery because
we're going away from the heart is it a
pulmonary artery no we're not dealing
with the lungs anymore the lungs we
dealt with the lungs we went from the
right ventricle went to the lungs in a
loop back to the left atrium now when
we're in the left ventricle we pump we
pump into the aorta now this is to go to
the rest of the body this is an artery a
non-pulmonary artery and it is
oxygenated
and i want to make this so when we're
dealing with non-pulmonary arteries
we're oxygenated but a pulmonary artery
has no oxygen it has to it's going away
from the heart to get the oxygen
pulmonary vein comes from the lungs to
the heart with oxygen but the rest of
the veins go to the heart without oxygen
because they want to go into that loop
on the pulmonary loop right there so
i'll leave you there hopefully that
gives actually let's let's go back to
that first diagram i think you have a
sense of how the the heart is dealing
but let's go look at the rest of the
body and just get a sense of things i
can you know i can you know you can look
this up on wikipedia if you like all of
these different branching points have
different names to them but you can see
right here
you can see right here you have a
kind of a branching off a little bit
below the heart this is actually the
celiac trunk
celiac
trunk celiac if i remember correctly
kind of refers to an abdomen so this
this blood the your the blood that your
hepatic artery hepatic deals with
the liver
your hepatic artery branches off of this
to get blood flow to the liver it also
gives blood flow to your stomach so it's
you know it's very important when
digestion and all of that and then let's
say this is the hepatic trunk you know
your liver is sitting like that hepatic
trunk it delivers oxygen the liver the
liver is using the is doing respiration
it takes up the oxygen and then
and then it gives up carbon dioxide so
it becomes deoxygenated and it flows
back in
it flows back in into the inferior vena
cava into the vein i want to make it
clear it's a loop it's a big loop the
blood that doesn't like just flow out
someplace and then come back someplace
else this is just one big loop and if
you want to know at any given point in
time depending on your size there's
about five liters
five liters
of blood and i looked it up on average
it takes the average red blood cell to
go from the one point in the circulatory
system and go through the whole system
and come back 20 seconds but that's an
average because you can imagine there
might be some blood red blood cells that
get stuck someplace and take a little
bit more time and some go through the
completely perfect route actually the 20
seconds might be closer to the perfect
route i've never timed it myself but
it's an interesting thing to look at and
to think about what's connected to what
that you have these uh these arteries up
here that they
first branch off the arteries up here
into from the aorta into the the head
and the uh the neck and the arm arteries
and then later they go down and then you
they they they flow blood to the rest of
uh
to the rest of the body so anyway this
is a pretty interesting idea in the next
video what i want to do is talk about
how does
how do
how does the hemoglobin know how does it
know when to dump the oxygen or even
better where to dump the oxygen because
you know maybe i'm running so i need a
lot of oxygen in the capillaries around
my thigh muscles i don't need them
necessarily in my hands how does the
body optimize where the oxygen is
actually delivering it's actually
fascinating